are you afraid of death
let's start with an easy question
there's no warm-up that's it
they're jumping jacks let's uh
let's break that down into two questions
um i'm a human being
and like any human being i'm
biologically
programmed to be terrified of death
every
physical element in our bodies is
designed to keep us away from death
i'm no different from anyone else in
that regard if you
throw me from the top of the entire
state building i'm going to scream all
the way down to the concrete
if you wave a loaded firearm in my face
i'm going to flinch away in horror the
same way
anyone else would um so
in that first sense of are you afraid of
death
uh my my body is
terrified of injury leading to death the
same way
any other human being would so when
death is imminent
there's a terror that goes through the
same adrenaline dumps that you would go
through
um uh but on the other hand you're also
asking a much deeper question which is
presumably are you afraid of
non-existence what comes
after your physical death and that's the
more interesting question
um no uh i should start
right by by scene from from the start
i'm a materialist i don't believe that
we have an immortal soul i don't believe
there's a life
after our physical death um in this
sense from someone who
starts from that point of view you have
to understand that
everyone has two deaths
we always talk about our death as though
there was only one
but we all have two deaths there was a
time before you were born
when you were dead
you weren't afraid of that period of
non-existence
you don't even think about it so why
would you be afraid
of your second period of non-existence
you came from non-existence
you're going to go back into it you
weren't afraid of the first
why are you somehow afraid of the second
so it doesn't really make sense to me
as to why people would be afraid of
non-existence you dealt with it fine the
first time
deal with it the second time but your
mind didn't exist
for the first death and it won't exist
after you die either
but it does exist now enough to
comprehend that there's this
thing that you know nothing about that's
coming which is non-existent actually
you do know about it because you know
what it was like before you were born
there was just nothing
every every every time you go to sleep
at night you get a sneak preview of
death
it's just this kind of
nothing happens you wake up in the
morning you're alive again
but it's not about the sleeping it's
about the falling asleep
and every night when you fall asleep you
assume you're going to wake up here you
know
you're not waking up and the knowledge
but there's a whole step from that
to the idea of fearing it i'm fully
aware that there's going to be a
time i don't wake up but are you going
to be afraid of it is there some mortal
terror you have of this no you didn't
have it before
you don't have it when you sleep um
going from
the fact that you know you won't wake up
to terror is
two different things that's an extra
step and at that point you're making a
choice at that
at that point what about what some
people
in our in this context we might call
like the third death which is
when um everybody forgets
the entirety of consciousness in the
universe forgets that you've ever
existed that john donahue
ever existed so it's almost like a
cosmic death it's like everything goes
yeah not not just i would say it's like
knowledge
the history books forget about who you
are because the history books
this is inevitable by the way we're all
very very small players in a very big
game
and inevitably we're all going to go at
some point
yeah but doesn't do your it's it's
disappointing of course
but but it's not even it would be
arrogance to say um
i'm disappointed in the idea that i will
disappear but there's there's far
greater things than me that will
disappear i mean it
it's crushing to think that
there's going to come a time when no one
will ever hear beethoven symphonies
again
that the the mysteries of the pharaohs
will be lost and no one will even
comprehend it they once existed like
humanity has come up with so many
amazing things over
its existence and to think that one day
this is just all happening on a tiny
speck in a distant corner of a very
small
galaxy and among millions of galaxies
that
this is all for nothing okay i can
understand there's a kind of dread that
comes with this
um but there's also a sense in which the
moment you're born and the moment you
can think about these things you know
this is your
inevitable fate is it so inevitable so
if we
look at we're in austin and there's a
guy named elon musk
and he's hoping in fact that is the
drive behind many of his passions
is the human beings becoming
multi-planetary species
and expanding out exploring and
colonizing
the solar system the galaxy and maybe
the rest of the universe
is that something that fills you with
excitement uh it's
as a project it's very exciting i um
the whole i mean we all grew up with
science fiction the idea of uh of
exploration the same way
uh human beings in earlier centuries
were thrilled with the idea of
discovering a new world
you know america or some other part of
the world that they
sailed to and come back but now instead
of sailing oceans
you're sailing solar systems and
ultimately
even further um so of course that's
exciting but
as far as relieving us from
non-existence it's just plain a delaying
game because ultimately
even the universe itself if the laws of
thermodynamics are correct will
ultimately die of course we might not
understand
most of the physics and how
the universe functions you said laws of
thermodynamics but maybe that's just a
tiny little
fraction of what the universe actually
is maybe there's multiple dimensions
maybe
maybe there's multiple universes maybe
the entirety of this experience
you know there's guys like donald
hoffman that think that all of this is
just an illusion that we don't
like human cognition and perception
constructs a whole it's like a video
game it would construct that's very
distant from the actual reality
and maybe one day we'll understand that
reality maybe it'll be like the matrix
kind of thing
so there's a lot of different
possibilities here and there's also a
philosopher
named ernest becker i don't know if you
know that is he wrote
denial of death and his idea he
disagrees with you but he's dead now
uh is is that
he thinks that the terror of death the
terror of the knowledge that we're going
to die
is within all of us and is in fact the
driver behind
most of the creativity that we do
exploring out into the universe
but also you becoming one of the great
scholars of the martial arts the
philosophers
of fighting is because you're actually
terrified of death
and you want you want to somehow
permeate
like your knowledge your ideas your
essence to permeate
human civilization so that even when
your
body dies you live on
i would agree with him and so far as uh
death
is the single greatest motivator for
action
but going beyond that and saying that
it's somehow
terrifying that's that's an extra step
on his part
um and not everyone's going to follow
him on that step
i do believe that death is
the single most important element in
life
that gives value to our days if you
think for example of a situation where
a god came to you and gave you
immortality
life would be very very different for
you uh
you're a talented research scientist
um you work to a schedule why
because ultimately you know your life is
finite and
actually very finite and
could be even more so if fate plays its
hand and you
uh uh die an early death or what have
you we never know what's going to happen
tomorrow
um as such we get work done
as soon as we can the moment you gain
immortality
you can always put every project off you
can always say
i don't need to do this today because i
can do it
four centuries from now and as you
extend
artificially a human life the motivation
to get things done here and now
and work industriously and and excel
fades away because you can always come
back to the idea that you can do this in
the future
and so what gives value to our days is
ultimately death and value
it's not the only form of the reason
behind value but a huge part of what we
consider value is scarcity and death
gives us scarcity of days
and is probably the single greatest
motivator for
almost every action we partake in
it's kind of tragic and beautiful that
what what makes things amazing
is that they end
yeah i think it would actually be a
terrible burden to be an immortal
you would um
life would be in many ways very hollow
and meaningless i think
people talk about death taking away the
meaning of life but
i think immortality would have a very
similar effect in a different direction
you